Yeah right so I want to talk about Star
Trek Picard Star Trek Picard the series
on CBS all access CBS right yeah I
personal I was waiting for Star Trek
Picard to wrap up so I can just binge
the whole thing I'm really glad I did
because if I had if I watch this week to
week I'm gonna kind of driven me nuts
especially since it goes through three
episodes before they get into space I
don't give you a spoiler warning right
here I'm just gonna talk about spoilers
and sometimes I might by habit try to
keep it vague but in the end if you
haven't watched Star Trek Picard I'm
about to spoil a lot of stuff for you so
you know only if you care let's take her
out if you've watched it or you don't
care all right so now the spoiler
warnings done so that Mass Effect show
who saw that coming the Star Trek Picard
picks up 20 years after the last time we
saw Picard OB Star Trek nemesis probably
my least favorite of the next generation
movies which is funny because when it
came out if that was so metal and I
rewatched the next generation movies
recently because I've been binging the
series as well again because I love that
show I was like yeah this is my least
favorite
so nemesis is kin and so is the
supernova that wiped out
Romulus in in the Abrams moving Abrams
movies cannon I mean not that this is
the alternate timeline because this is
still on the original timeline is in the
future the Abrams movies are still in
the Biff alternate timeline ponies we
now run into a Picard who is left
Starfleet because it's it's not
Starfleet anymore which is right
Starfleet's pretty much like shield or
shield was invaded by Hydra and
everyone's dicks now it's kind of like
that feels like that but this girl shows
up and she's an Android and he's like oh
I'm gonna help you because you have
dangerous code in your head because she
gets blown up so he's on the search for
her twin now he gets a new cruise ship
and they're going they're basically
following breadcrumbs it's a mystery
it's actually really fitting since data
was a huge Sherlock Holmes fan I
actually appreciate that about this show
the fact that it's not just a space
adventure and firefights take a ship
take the enterprise park it over a
planet and then have the scenario play
out and then give us a life lesson at
the end and sweet Star Trek I don't need
the space adventure firefighter this
actually doesn't try to be a space
adventure firefight it tries to be a
mystery which is one of my favorite
old-school Star Trek movies is a mystery
Star Trek 6 the undiscovered country
it's like things I enjoyed are in the
show and things that made me go alright
what I like like I said I like the fact
that there is a mystery going on
though the mystery isn't really a proper
it's not an unveiling of information as
you would think it should be I mean they
follow breadcrumbs that's for sure but
it's like I think it was episode 7 or 8
I can't remember which all-in-one
conversation it's like there's this
roundtable of exposition plot vomit
they're like okay here's everything you
need to know and it comes at you so fast
your head spins I had to watch it like
two or three times okay so how are the
androids and what was the okay he shot
two other wait they were emissary what
what it just felt like it came at a
hundred miles an hour I'm still trying
to talk about things I liked but hey
we're just kind of leapfrogging so I
didn't like the fact that they were like
well here are a lot of unknowns we're
gonna try to figure it out here's all
the info in a case like this I gotta
prioritize what I'm gonna talk about
like am I going to talk about things
that are genuinely is like oh these are
plot elements that come introduced
something or maybe I didn't like them or
do I want to nitpick because there's a
lot of nitpicks that I could do in here
I mean I love jean-luc Picard he's one
of the greatest characters in television
of all time among one of the greatest
shows of all time in the end when he
left Starfleet
that's this friend that he had 15 years
ago was she just kind of went on a
bender and became estranged from her son
and he never checked up on like who's
gonna grow these grapes in the vineyard
that's the important stuff I guess he
just didn't care I means that nitpick
possibly it's also a personality trait
but I like how the show dealt with
Romulan lore you know the Romulans
essentially they think they're being the
good guys which every villain is the
hero in their own story but the Romulans
were always you know the bad guys are on
the other side of the war the other side
of the tension and so it's like we never
really knew much about them other than
they were really militant and very
strict and they have a super secret
organization called the Tal Shiar
that's what we knew Bush actually is it
comes into play here we get a little
more behind the scenes of the Romulans
like there's a there's a female order of
super-secret assassins like not Tal
Shiar but like ninjas or something
that's pretty it's sabor gay there's
this Borg cube which the the Romulans
call the artifacts which he was in it
Hugh from the episode I Borg I've always
liked Hugh that's a classic episode I
was glad to see he [ __ ] that he died but
I was glad to see Hugh because not only
do we get
the seams of the Romulans but you see
more of the Borg as well because it
started humanizing the Borg's
you always knew the Borg they're
assimilated people but if you get
someone out of assimilation if you
unhook them and you know they're human
again they remember everything so
they're still there when that kind of
clicks with you you're like well there
are victims of the circumstance they're
victims of the hive it's easy to see
them as the scary cyborg space zombies
but I like the fact that it's like
another people and we're trying to get
them back I thought that was neat though
what exactly did the cube do other than
existing other than you know it's a Borg
cube and Borg are cool I thought it was
gonna play some huge role because this
whole thing about little synthetic life
and maybe the Borg are gonna play into
not really at a point even 7 & 9 hooks
into us like we are Borg just like I'm
gonna stage a coup they're like open the
airlock just blow up all the drones out
into space was like rad to Jack [ __ ] so
didn't really serve anything other than
being a pretty sweet thing that got a
few people to the end location before
Mass Effect the best I can assess it's
like because I was like what broke the
Borg ship and best I can figure is when
all these Romulans got this vision of
this apocalypse where synthetics are
gonna wipe out organics and when those
Romulans were assimilated into the Borg
collective that concept that knowledge
just broke the Borg essentially they
were like synthetics and organics wait
we were both nope not dealing with it
and it just cracked it and broke the
cube I guess I don't know the show's not
really that clear on it so I assume
that's it which actually brings me to 79
I thought she was great I thought I
liked where they brought seven of nine I
thought I liked where she was in the
show just made sense to me she's like
this nomadic bounty hunter kind of
person and that made sense that she
would be that and she's less Borg
because whereas in Voyager she spent
most of her life in the collective she's
been Borg most of her life and now she's
been human for most of her life so it
made sense that she was more human it
would it showed evolution with her I
mean people in this show they flip-flop
a lot this person's pissed at that
person and then they're totally cool
with that person she's like I just
murdered my colleague lover and probably
boyfriend but whatever I can just [ __ ]
this guy also pretty sure I got away
with murder cuz no one cares I did it
anymore the captain I liked we don't
have dash Rendar in a movie or a show
this dude's pretty much the closest
we've gotten yet which I laughed my ass
off when Picard's like I know Starfleet
and you are Starfleet to the
cause I was like what about that guy is
Starfleet what is it's a big piece of
shrapnel in his arm well he has a cigar
in his mouth like this nothing what this
guy should be in some hole in the wall
Moss Eisley spaceport with Bubba Fett
getting all the Twi'lek chicks he can
look there's nothing Starfleet about her
but have a philosophical spirit as well
bit of a philosopher like that is what I
like about him you know he's that space
pirate quality you don't think you're
gonna have a deep conversation with them
but it'll hit you with the whole human
beings define themselves by their own
mortality and the fact that their lives
end which is a solid foreshadow but you
never know it's not a foreshadow you're
never like whatever that's gonna
boomerang back around you know it will
but I like the fact that he has that
vibe about him but he's former Starfleet
kind of reminded me like I don't know
Malcolm Reynolds from Firefly or
something he has that damage to him not
saying this show is as good as Firefly
or Mass Effect's I'm saying there's a
similarity of some sort there's actually
the ship the inside kind of reminded me
of the Normandy as well also the fact
that the crew doesn't really like each
other at first definitely not Star Trek
more Mass Effect I also like seeing Will
Riker cuz Will Riker is amazing he's
great I like scene where Will Riker and
Deanna Troi were at this point though I
will say that monologue that speech Will
Riker gives Picard about how to be a
father because I guess Picard doesn't
know how to be a father
that's [ __ ] I want - Picard to be
like [ __ ] I've been a father to
to a grandfather - one I've been a
father to a daughter father to a son and
I was pretty good at it because the
inner light happened that episodes the
one of the best episodes of TNG ever
it's real I'll teach you how to be a
father you know thank me later it's just
interesting that makes me go like did
they watch next generation before they
made this show they actually Bruce
Maddox is the scientist who actually
created Dana's daughter in this show or
daughters he's a pivotal character
that's a deep cut from season two of
next gender I think it's season two the
episodes called measure of a man
basically data's on trial for whether or
not he is sentient I'm glad they knew
about him know about the inner light
though well so people in the show don't
ask questions funny because it's a
mystery they're supposed to not a lot of
questions being asked when the super spy
when o grabs the doctors head and gives
her this vision of this apocalypse he's
never once like look is this your fear
some memory like what is this because
all right oh I guess I believe you
enough to kill my boyfriend there's a
scene where there's a tractor beam on
the main ship and they just let them go
and the captain's like sweet they're not
gonna follow us at all they just let us
go because I don't know
they're nice I'm not gonna question it
let's just go and definitely be followed
that was stupid even the whole plot
revolves around a bunch of synthetics
who snapped and killed everybody on Mars
and that stopped Federation production
of any and all synthetics all studies
are out because I guess the Federation
was like well we're just gonna write
that one off as a big mistake no no
investigation necessary I get that
there's a Romulan mole as the head of
security and the Federation but this is
the biggest catastrophe in the solar
system ever that one person is able to
roadblock the investigation I feel like
there'd be a lot more questions from the
Federation Council just go ahead and not
even ask questions when I look at Picard
you know like there were a couple of
times in the show where Picard is
interacting giving his thoughts whatever
he's doing and I tried to you know put
Picard from next generation in that
situation to think like how would he
deal with this I think it's I think it
is a bit different granted he's older
now he's I guess a little more broken
even when they find that you know like
oh that girl was being tracked and then
she gave herself a shot which
neutralized it but it sent her into a
coma they're all like Picard she's the
spy and he's like well we don't know
that just like all evidences point yeah
we do I feel like old Picard would have
been like keep me informed Beverly he'd
totally be open to the prospect and idea
of that it's like look I heard she digs
men who are old enough to be her father
look just fingers crossed to the main
plot is they they followed to this
planet and on this planet where dr.
Soong I guess has a son which is scandal
aim to be honest with you what doctors
doing at his son but data and lore will
end before I guess but that was I always
took that as dr. Soong was like I don't
have children so these are my children
after Alton in a ghost song mad
scientist
my father had me but he created data
they never let me forget I would think
this guy would be a bartender somewhere
be like [ __ ] robotic said my dad was a
dick I think this would have been a
great opportunity to bring Laura back
into it to be honest with you cuz the
plots come something we already saw with
Laura the two-part episode
descent where lore kind of took charge
of this group of Borg who's trying to
wipe out the organic life and synthetics
would rule all hey that's the plot of
Star Trek Picard why not bring lower
back cuz Laura's last words to data
where I love you brother
he could be like I love my brother and
Picard could be like you're perverting
everything he stood for long but on this
planet data's daughter is going to be
the Redeemer or the destroyer the pond
Oh Messiah welcome time Spencer welcome
to your destiny you either know it or
you don't but with a beam that shoots up
to a portal and opens up a portal these
synthetics are gonna come through and
just wipe out all organics in this
galaxy oh and it's happened before this
does sound familiar
it just cracks me up at first I was like
oh Normandie vibes from the ship look at
that then I was like oh this is Mass
Effect which at that point I have
questions I just do I just not that I
have answers I just have questions when
dr. Soong was creating synthetic life
that would be data and lore though he
never gets credit everyone always
forgets about Laura the Romulans were
like all right we need someone in the
Federation to basically stop that
otherwise synthetic life is gonna build
and then this apocalypse is gonna come
so the Romulans are trying to stop this
apocalypse so as long as synthetics
never hit that line this apocalypse of
Reapers they're not gonna happen well I
have a 40-year plan to wipe out Mars to
stop it like a show pretty heavily
emphasizes that no one could recreate
dr. Soong's work even the new synthetics
are built off of a piece of datas
positronic matrix so data is really key
and data's in Starfleet you have a mole
in Starfleet you have a mole working in
the same place that the only real
synthetic you have to worry about the
key that's gonna trickle to everything
is there some pretty good access to him
I imagine Oh wasn't director of security
yet sure fine but it'd just be like hey
let's hang out sometime yeah let's just
go down this really seedy alley to be
sure right well these vaporize now I
guess I'm gonna go back to the Romulan
Empire because my job here is clearly
done and now you have a much bigger
problem to deal with because you were
like no we're gonna wait what why not
just wait in a world where Romulans with
good intent can get to a Federation
officer kidnapper and surgically alter
her for their own scheme I'm sure ROM
with bad intent which I guess like I
said before they see themselves as
heroes oh yeah I'm pretty sure Romulans
can get to lieutenant commander data
somehow if they really wanted to I mean
that Romulan defector in the episode of
the defector he could have just been
some spy and be like oh your lieutenant
come I'd appreciate a vaporizer you know
what I'm going to jail I know but took
one for the team right take me to
Federation jail you guys whatever you
can put me in a Cell anyway you're not
gonna execute me I mean if Agnes melted
her boyfriend's cardiovascular system
I'm pretty sure any Romulan would have
taken one for the team to vaporize Dana
in the end this wasn't supposed to be a
play-by-play of the plot really think so
I'm not walking you to the end of the
plot but I gotta wrap up my saying
really it's any time there was something
cool that I liked there was the flip
side of it it's like yeah but I don't
like that like example it was amazing
seeing Will Riker on the bridge of a
ship again that was great I love the
fact that we'll came in to help Picard
who didn't actually ask him to do that
it shows how much Picard loves Will
Riker it shows how much Will Riker loves
Picard it was a great moment of
friendship and it was awesome to see
Riker in uniform however what the entire
Armada of Federation ships they're all
the same ship that seems kind of lazy
why I mean production is why that's
that's exactly why easy to make one ship
and didn't copy and paste and now you
have a hundred ships but they're all the
same ship could you have made five
different ones and rotated them make it
look anyhow as you seemed kind of lazy
also didn't like the weird device that
fixes things with imagination because
you could tell they were like alright
how do we limp them along until the
Federation gets there well we got to
make make it look like there's a lot of
ships going up against a lot of ships
how there's only one ship I don't know
we'll just make a device that can do it
I guess I sweet we made a device that'll
pretty much make the shredder fight from
Ninja Turtles the arcade game and for
the longest time the shell was like I'm
not really buying the whole shoji thing
it was because Shoji and I don't know
what's his name [ __ ] Romulan guy
Romulan spy that everyone knew he was a
spy cuz the show said he was a spy but
even in the show he who sniffed out the
fact that he's a spy he's like oh you
mean the spy yeah I know he's a spy
still hate that he died it's he was a
favorite of mine from the series when I
started appreciating the fact that
Picard's there because this is the last
remnant
of his friend and he owes it to his
friend to save the last piece of him and
I dug that those like the inner light
didn't happen I didn't like that and at
the end well she's gonna open a portal
and wipe everyone out with the Reapers
she turns back because Picard speech
card speech will stop anything in his
tracks at Picard speech kittens and
skittles not as effective on world peace
as a good Picard speech and I like the
fact that he did have a good speech and
Picard does have lessons to throw out
there and the show actually had lessons
about consciousness and individuality
and what is life and you are not your
past you're not where you come from your
life is your life to live and if people
are so lucky they get to experience it
with you we are who we choose to be also
not acting out of fear because all the
Romulans this whole thing is enacted out
of fear and when people act from a place
of fear bad things happen because like
fear anxiety that that fight or flight
is supposed to be something that
provokes you into action for that quick
moment where you need to call 911 that
moment where you need to take action to
help someone save something save
yourself help yourself get something
done very quickly right now but when you
live there in that bubble of fear and
anxiety and you make decisions from that
it usually doesn't lead to good things
so I actually enjoyed that the show had
that Picard has a brain condition and so
he dies at the end and then he gets
brought back as one of those basically
Cylons from Battlestar Galactica human
robots that for all intents and purposes
are indistinguishable from humans but I
guess they're technically synthetics
basically the only thing that's
different about them is that he doesn't
have the brain thing anymore he's gonna
live as long as he would have and he
would have a real heart not an
artificial one anymore so I was like why
did you kill him just to bring him back
however you do get a really heartfelt
goodbyes between Picard and data it's a
nice goodbye and it's a much better one
one that I would have preferred was in
Star Trek nemesis but you didn't really
get that so for better for worse I
appreciated that I got that between
those two characters in here even plays
blue skies from Star Trek nemesis nice
touch so it's kind of a funny thing that
happened with me and Star Trek Picard I
left Star Trek Picard like I got done
with it I was immediately thinking about
the things that didn't remind me of next
generation and things that bothered me
but as I kept thinking about it
I appreciated more the things that I did
enjoy about it I don't think this show
stuck all the landings or something like
I've just recently mentioned some plot
lines rolls like that doesn't really
make sense to me some dialogue okay not
Star Trek The Next Generation I'll
absolutely say that yeah you can't go
into this expecting Star Trek The Next
Generation I'm gonna Star Trek The Next
Generation back you know because
Picard's in it you can't do that some of
the themes they touch on in Picard
they've already touched on in next
generation exactly is the definition of
life character ergo sum I think that's
what I have however from Star Trek being
made in 2020 I thought it would feel a
lot worse
I enjoyed it more than I didn't I do
think that the show probably could have
been half as long as it was there's
enough to enjoy as long as you know that
you're not getting next generation it's
like by the end of this Picard's a space
pirate or something and you know deep
down he's always wanted to be a space
pirate and now he gets to be a space
pirate of some sort I mean not an
[ __ ] but just a little more nomadic
like Picard on serenity in the show
Firefly or something what are he and
this ragtag crew what are they gonna do
I don't know but it's kind of a cool
thought so I'm interested it's kind of
wanna see where they take this a thing I
do find strange is that they say [ __ ]
here I don't know why I find it so weird
you know I don't give a [ __ ] for a while
I don't care about curse words say do
you care about continuity of universe
and that's new to Star Trek it feels
different you know like james t kirk is
like oh this colorful metaphors that's
simply the way they talk in the 20th
century people don't notice you don't
stand out in a crowd unless you swear a
B couple word sure
[ __ ] hubris apparently that's how they
talk in the 24th century if you have
people in a Star Trek story speaking
differently than how people are used to
them speaking people aren't gonna
perceive it as Star Trek language so it
just it felt weird to me alright so Star
Trek Picard have you seen it why did you
think about it are you a Star Trek The
Next Generation fan do you care D now
Karen if you're a next generation fan
what's your favorite episode or episodes
I'll start it out here we go there's a
lot best of both worlds
inner light tapestry chain of commands
yesterday's enterprise ship-in-a-bottle
Eyeborg
relics too many to name but those are a
few well whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see
click right here to see him lawyer
[Music]